sont des dizaines à fuir les
bombardements à l'ouest de kiev mais il
préfère aujourd'hui partie rapide sur
qu'importe les conditions
juste à côté les dizaines de bus
d'évacuation eux restent vides à l'arrêt
sur les parkings pourtant la russie se
targue ce matin d'avoir ouvert des
couloirs humanitaires
aujourd'hui à 10 heures heure de moscou
un régime de silence a été déclarée six
couloirs humanitaires sont ouverts
pendant ce temps les forces armées
russes effectuent une surveillance
objectifs continus de l'évacuation à
l'aide de drones
voici les six couloirs mise en place par
la russie tous ceux qui permettent de
sortir du créneau même temps biélorussie
ou même directement en russie
inconcevable pour beaucoup d'habitants
il préfère attendre dans des abris
malgré le risque plutôt que de les
emprunter
je ne crois aucun mot de ce que dit la
russie je ne pense pas que les corridors
humanitaires ouvert par la russie car
soient de vrais corridor
je suis d'accord
nous ne pouvons faire confiance qu'aux
informations du gouvernement ukrainien
selon certains experts ces couloirs
humanitaires sont une énième manoeuvre
du kremlin
c'est de la prise d'otages c'est du
cynisme donc entre la vie et la
soumission c'est ça c'est un choix
dramatique pour les ukrainiens
kiev annonce ce matin refusé cette
option qu'elle juge inacceptable
de nouvelles négociations entre la
russie et l'ukraine sont prévues cet
après midi